so hi everybody thank you for being here
so this talk is about unclear code
one approach to talk about unclear code
would be to start from clean code or
from its definition that we could find
for example looking at what influential
software engineers or best selling
authors said
for example one of the most famous book
about clean code is clean code by romeo
martin and i suggest you to read it if
you haven't already it's very very
interesting but we are not going to
follow this uh top-down approach here
after all i am neither an influential
software engineer nor a best-selling
author and i couldn't be able to define
in such beautiful ways what clean code
is for me however i think i know
what unclear code looks like or at least
it's feeling the feeling when you
write or read it
we could say
it starts as a surprise as if something
magical is happening behind the scenes
and you're not getting it and the more
you stare at the code and can't
understand it the more it becomes
frustration or
distress
and i think i'm not the only one here
probably many of us had similar feelings
at least once in their life so i will
follow this bottom up approach to clean
code talking about what unclear code
meant for me
so this discussion won't be
exhaustive about this very broad topic
but we'll just focus on some aspects
that emerge from three stories about
three different characters an astronomer
a data scientist and a software engineer
they are all taken quite literally from
my personal experience
there will be quite a few lines of code
they will try to read and interpret and
trying to understand if they are good
code or bad code through the
consequences they had on our characters
i hope you will be able to relate to
them in some way and hopefully by the
end of the talk you will have more ideas
about how to write cleaner code and
communicate better your intentions
my name is dario canone and i write
python code since my phd in physics the
first story comes from that time then i
worked a couple of years in consultancy
while in the last four years
i've worked for an italian company that
is leader in the market of credit
related outsourcing services like for
banks and for entrances where i was the
first
senior hire of the newly created machine
learning team
and one of my goals was to build the
team itself besides
laying the foundation of the initial
machine learning code base and
infrastructure the second and third
stories come from that period
so let's start with the first one so
imagine you are you are a nully career
researcher or a phd student in astronomy
you're working with the photometry of
variable stars that is you are studying
how the light of this particular kind of
stars evolves in time
and one of your goals at the moment is
to make complicated plots like this one
that show how this light is somewhat
this variability is somewhat predictable
in time there's patterns
so but before you can even try to
make one of these plots
you need to understand better your data
because you don't know it very well you
have some data with observation from
some stars and you just want now to be
able to print some summary information
about this data set so you talk with
this colleague of yours and she tells
you that she has a function written in
python that can help to do this dirty
job for you and
so
she gives you this print info function
you use it on your data set and this is
the output you you have on your terminal
quite easy to interpret the table with
uh
on
different rows you have different stars
and every
column is a different
quantity measured on that star
but there's something
that's not really clear there are
underscores here and there
uh they may be missing values but you're
not sure and there's a bottom row with
integer numbers that you weren't
expecting so the only thing you can do
now is to
uh take a look at the code and trying to
understand what's going on so you open
the file
and
wow
okay
it isn't supposed to be hard science
but
uh
written in this way is quite impossible
to read like
there is a weird use of spacing and
indentation and multiple line collapse
two single ones with semicolons and
lines that are long up to 300 characters
so
yeah there's no point in trying to do
something here you are forced to rewrite
it so yeah
let's try to do it
you noticed that somewhere there there
was the there were the names of the
variables the name they were on the
columns of the table so you single them
out and you put them at the beginning
then there are some variables count that
are initialized to zero but yeah we will
see later what they are used for and
then the header of the table is printed
that was easy at least
then a for loop starts that must be
where the rows of the table are printed
and indeed
that is what's
happening so row by row this number are
printed taken from the input data set
and whenever
some number is equal to zero or is null
then an underscore is printed instead so
yes we guessed it right the underscores
were missing values
if we move on
we also find a nested for loop where
missing values are counted and the
initial the variables that were
initialized to 0 are updated
and finally printed as a bottom row so
the bottom row was the count of missing
values
just to summarize at the beginning of
this function the header is printed
then
in a for loop row by row all the numbers
are printed and when there's some
missing values
underscores are substituted and finally
my missing values are counted and
printed as a last as a bottom row so we
did it but it wasn't easy and it wasn't
free
and when written in this file in this
way that function was perfectly working
but was completely unreadable and we had
to spend time and energy just to rewrite
it and our
ad and the update value to our research
in astronomy was zero
so the astronomer
learned the hard way that readability
can count and probably in the future
we'll think more about it
but actually there's no need to be
creative about how to write
well-formatted codes there are
guidelines you may have heard about
prepaid
and also if you want work even less then
automatically formatters like black can
help
of course readability is not the most
important point about writing good code
but it's usually the step zero after
which we can reason about more
interesting stuff for example here i
noticed that the astronomers colleague
is more of a c programmer maybe than a
python programmer the function is
not really pythonic and also
this function is trying to tell me that
it just prints some information
i'm looking at its name but inside
uh we discovered that it also found and
counted missing values and this point
about doing
uh more than one thing
uh in the same place is what brings us
to our next example
this story
is about my first days as a data
scientist in my previous job
when i was struggling with the training
of some neural network
in the field of machine learning you
usually find yourself with some model
that you want to train on some data set
so that it learns to perform some tasks
like in my case there were
classification tasks
about documents or emails and i wanted
this model to be able to predict the
classes of some of these documents and
emails and of course i also wanted to
validate the prediction of those models
to tell if the model was good or bad
so
i knew that i was going to repeat all
this process of training and validating
and predicting uh over and over again so
i thought
yes i am doing all these steps
many times so better to write a general
function the wrap that wraps all these
steps together and so that i can forget
about the rest and just use this
function also my team will do this the
same for many other projects so this
function will be so general convenient
and time saving that everybody will love
it so i started to write this function
at the beginning
there was just the model i wanted to
train on some training data set x train
and y train for some ebooks so ebooks in
neural network jargon is just the number
of steps i'm sorry for this completely
uh
so
epochs steps in the neural network
jargon during of the training so all my
for how much time do i want to train the
um
the model for
and for every epoch i completed accuracy
on the validation data set x val and y
val but of course accuracy is not the
only metric in machine learning one
could want to use other metrics so yeah
better to live
this freedom to the user so that they
can use
whatever metric they want to to track
but also now we are computing these
metrics for every step so we may want to
be able to stop the training when one of
these metrics is not improving anymore
uh there's no need no no point in
keeping on training the model if metrics
are not improving so yeah i did early
stopping this is a very
well known procedure in machine learning
two more parameters to account for early
stopping
also training and machine learning could
be very long so
if they fail for any way we may want to
be able to resume the training later so
yeah
let's add a way to checkpoint the model
let's save the model in a certain
frequency like every one or two or five
epochs
and so that we could be able to resume
the training later
but also now i have a trained model i
may want to
learn something about this model like
uh what i mean did it learn anything
so yes let's also the possibility to
look at the internal parameters of this
neural network in our case in the neural
network case we call them weights and
activations so plots for every epoch or
when i want like again with a certain
frequency like every one five ten ebooks
uh very good now this function is very
powerful
and it could be slow so yeah yeah maybe
better to add the possibility to
subsample the data set so that i can
train the model only on a subset of the
data and of course we are all very good
data scientists so do not forget about
setting the random state for
reproducibility but what if my team at
some point wants to customize the
training even further
icing on the cake more keyword arguments
for everyone
so
very powerful function i was very happy
with it
and i get pushed
to the dysfunction to the common
repository waiting for my team to use it
result
nobody ever use it even i didn't use it
and that was uh
yeah i must have been that that hurts
but if i look at it now
it isn't that surprising i mean what
what does this function try what is
trying to do like training the model
validating the model maybe analyzing a
trained model monitoring the training of
a model probably everything but if it's
not easy to explain that it's probably a
bad idea there was a hard lesson but it
taught me about premature optimization
and complexity
this function is
it's not doing anything really it's just
a wrapper around something else like
tensorflow that was uh doing the the
dirty job about training the neural
network but it wasn't reducing the
complexity of all those steps i exposed
so many parameters to the users they had
to choose many things they had to learn
many things and at the end nobody use it
nobody could even probably understand it
many programmers among you could tell me
that they violated two commonly known
principle of good software design the
keep it simple principle and you aren't
going to need it principle the function
was complex and redundant at the same
time and that's that was the reason why
nobody used it so
why did i write it that way probably i
just wanted to be general and i didn't
care didn't pay enough attention to what
the function was becoming parameter
after parameter
and i didn't care uh enough about the
cognitive load of the function that is
the effort one needs to uh put in
learning and trying to understand uh
that's the that piece of code
this point about cognitive load connects
us to our last story
so now you are a junior software
engineer in this new company your first
week this company works in the mortgage
process together with banks
so today
for the first time you're going to look
at the code base
of the software backend software that
manages the mortgage application process
you know nothing about mortgages
but this senior colleague of yours
told you that this part of the code at
least is simple enough that you can read
it and understand it by yourself
so you start
and
yeah at the beginning you find a house
class there's another attribute
address probably and a val
that must be the value of the house
okay then the mortgage application
class
looks more technical like amt
it's probably the amount of the loan
that a person can ask hs
should be the house itself after all
mortgage houses should be linked
somewhere and here um yeah but most
importantly this reminds me about the
astronomers story um here everything is
readable but still we are trying to
decipher what the authors wrote
if
it was just a bit more explicit it would
have been so much better
abbreviations
usually makes our life worse because
they force us to remember names that are
not worth remembering they impose
cognitive load
i didn't say always though there are
there sometimes they can be useful
in our case for example there is a
quantity that is the loan to value
quantity there is the fraction of the
value of the house that is covered by
the by the mortgage that is very
important and if i saw a code written in
this way where everything is so explicit
except for that term i understand that
the author is telling me that that term
is really important that i need to learn
it if i want to be successful in this
domain indeed in the business domain of
the mortgage process that term is really
known by everyone and use it every day
let's make a step further
let's add people to the game so a person
for us is just another class and
we can use it we can see on the right
hand side uh for
applying to a mortgage so alice that is
an instance
of a person
applies
to a mortgage that is an instance of a
mortgage application class
the its usage seems clear and the
implementation too is very
straightforward the apply method of the
class person just updates the
application attributes of the person and
the application applicant list of the
mortgage application
also looking at this piece of code i
could try to understand something about
again what the authors try to tell me i
see that there is the apply method for
the person but not the inverse ad
applicant for example method of the
mortgage application this suggests that
the author prefer to see this kind of
information flow a person that applies
to a mortgage and i won't expect in the
rest of the code to see the opposite way
around like a mortgage
instance to which person are added like
as applicants so i
written in this way where everything is
very clear and explicit i could also try
to interpret how the rest of the code
could work there are a couple of
subtleties though
for example applicant list
looks like a bit redundant
at least
and but also
naming things after the implementation
could be problematic what is uh what if
at some point someone wants to change
the internal
representation of uh that attribute to
dictionary because they need to look for
youth for people like with emails as
keys for a dictionary they would either
have then
incoherent attribute name or they need
to change the attribute name but even
even trickier
applications attribute of the person is
set
to a single mortgage application during
the apply method so what should i
understand here is the plural
just wrong
or maybe that that's a bug and
applications should be a list like the
applicant list in fact
does is a person allowed to
have more than one mortgage at the same
time
so as you can see even a very small
detail like a badly placed plural can
create confusion and make us wonder
about the business process that is
behind a very simple piece of software
so in our first
week as software engineers we have
already seen quite a few things
first
we
understood that abbreviations are
expensive and we should avoid it
unless they really really mean something
in the business domain we are working
with
then we were able to um understand and
reinterpret some of the intentions the
all of the authors of the code reading
between the lines and finally we um
could appreciate how even the smallest
details like a plural name could can
create confusion
so let me try to jump to a tentative
conclusion of this talk we have listened
to
three different stories about three
different characters an astronomer a
data scientist and a junior developer
they all shared a common experience they
learned first hand that unclear code can
hurt
in our first
story we talked about readability the
astronomer was given a perfectly working
function that was at the same time
unreadable and she had to waste time
just to rewrite the function if she
wanted to understand what was going on
in the second story we learned about
complexity the data scientist
motivated by the best of intention just
wasted his time
writing trying to write a general
function that was at the same time
complex and redundant and at the end
nobody used it
in the third story we
could
we learned about the importance of
naming we could uh try we could
interpret some of the intentions of the
authors
reading at what
they
write in the in their software and we
also could appreciate how even the
smallest details and our choices could
confuse readers
so if i have to
choose a take-home message from this
talk i would say that code is always
communication and that writing good code
is caring about all our future readers
including ourselves thank you
thank you thank you very much w so we
will start with the q a session uh
please
um go to slido and ask your questions so
we already have the first question
and it's what the what about the role of
comments and documentation to claire
clarify better what is happening here
and there
very good question thank you um
there are different
yeah different people say different
things about comments uh but they can be
really useful especially to make the
details of the implementation or the
choices that we as authors uh want to
want to make so yes they can be very
useful but they are not an excuse
like
there is no
way
it's not it's not um there should
shouldn't be any excuse to writing bad
code they can be redundant they can lie
comments lie and they are
expensive also to maintain because they
should be maintained like codes but they
are not code so
yes very useful and
no there shouldn't be an excuse to write
in bad code
sure thanks the next question is why did
you decide to not include type
annotations well good
there's the second part in my experience
they make everything more readable eg
prevent the plural confusion you
mentioned i completely agree
and yeah that was just a
choice that email choices that emerged
from some personal experience so
everything here is just uh in my
experience so yes i completely agree
with the uh with the author of the of
the question typings and annotations can
be really useful to make the code better
okay next question is have you ever
tried to drive the code to be clear
using tests
of course yes another very big part of
writing good code if you i mean also in
the book itself clean code test is one
of the
main part and actually probably
no one could define good code if it
doesn't run tests so yes
i completely again i agree
good
what if you have to write a very long
variable names to make it explainable
wow wolf
i think there's no
[Music]
okay there is no perfect rule there
uh
i tend to prefer
longer names
but
yeah but not too long uh so there's not
really uh
like rule them all solution
uh but then is where probably comments
and documentation come to help that that
could be one of the places where i would
use comments or a clearly written
document
okay
what's your take on heavy usage of funk
tools
i commonly hear the reason it looks
super clean although less experienced
engineers have to read a lot so funk
tools yes
funk tools okay i'm
not sure i
could understand completely the
question like anonymous offer maybe
change
yeah i'm sorry i'm not sure i could uh
understand
i mean if you want to if someone wants
to contribute
i'm happy to
i'm up to here there's no real um
yeah
thank you
i just reversed the
awesome awesome yeah
okay next question have you seen a
project consisting only of good code by
the book wow
plot twist no
i would like to say yes but no
of course or not
but yeah there's probably a limit
everyone wants to achieve but never
achieves
a never-ending
trial and effort sorry
sure
how strict are you about clean code when
reviewing prs for requests wow okay
you okay this question is about is
probably for my team
members for the other team members but
we could ask them probably but um
[Music]
yeah maybe a bit strict but no
i mean at some point you stop
complaining because if it works and if
it does the job
at some point it stops probably the
point is uh the the question i
uh
make to myself is
if i don't know
anything about this code how much do i
need how much time do i need to
understand at least the workflow at
least what is doing so if it's too much
if it's more than a quick look just to
have a quick understanding then i would
be strict otherwise if i can get the
idea but then there are some details
that are not really really good code
that who cares i mean let's move on to
to the next task and maybe maybe at some
point we come back then then we all know
what's happened but what happens but
yeah
great so is there a trick to write
cleaner code when writing gui's eg pi qt
i always struggle with lying too long
okay so
yeah many people struggle with lying too
long
there are beautiful talks i mean on in
youtube where there's also black itself
in this documentation says 90
so they're not really strict about lines
but no there's no
clean solution rule the mold solution
every every single point is a compromise
between your
uh the confusion you could have just
reading and writing the code and the
tools you you have at the moment
uh what tools are that informative can
you help us can help us to keep the
standards and simplify review yeah also
i didn't
of course i didn't uh talk about all the
uh ci and linking and all that stuff
that of course could be helpful i mean
all the automation that you could build
around writing with code linting and
black itself that that really helps of
course
all your history about amateurs they
cannot create normal code what can you
offer to decrease complexity for
professional teams
what can you offer sir what can you what
can you offer to decrease complexity for
professional teams
okay what can i offer so
well i don't know we could
talk later maybe that's something that i
could offer i could definitely offer it
but in general uh probably i could just
offer this experience about
the the the question i
ask myself when i do code reviews or i
see coder called written by others that
is
these questions about how much energy do
i need to understand how much time do i
need to to to understand is this clear
so uh
another rule of thumb that is not really
over but yeah
is
always for example
aim for the average programmer
not to the of course not to the
very beginning not to the beginners but
not
not to the
most expert ones because the expert ones
will of course understand i mean
whatever i mean they are really expert
and clever people um but and beginners
of course need to learn something but
the average programmer most of us
probably at least i uh am the average
programmer so
i think that
aiming for that big part really is the
one of the probably suggestions that
they could give
yeah
okay thank you so if your question
didn't answer yet
that you will be around thank you very
much
[Applause]